so today's topic or ladies sketch now
after we put out the video how to come
from someone saying hey why are you kind
of making up these situations and making
the satire piece to make feminism look
bad someone someone said that to you
yeah and I thought it was interesting
because in reality the video wasn't
really satire now I was basically
recreating real-world events that have
happened numerous times different and
placing them in all one video you know
the whole part about people kind is not
something I made up that all mankind was
create we prefer the term people kind
this is the Prime Minister of Canada
maternal love is the love that's going
to change the future of mankind
so we'd like you to look what we would
like to say people kind not necessarily
mankind more people kind not necessarily
mankind more inclusive why be man even
the idea of like someone storming this
stage and taking over Martin Luther
King's speeches not my thing you know
remember Bernie Sanders was taking over
during his speech by black lives matter
protesters so you know even for someone
who was is as progressive as Bernie
Sanders you know radical stuff on the
way to take over speech co-opted his
opportunity and actually hinder his
campaign like it was a big blow to him
you know it's just interesting to me
that people think I'm making this up I
don't make anything up even though the
craziness of the girl you know what I
even did I even quoted her why do you
hate us so
we don't hate you feminists hate the
patriarchy [ __ ] feminists hate
patriarchy right can I break something
what can I bring even the final line
which is sex oppressive
look Google it is a real article these
are real ideas that people are
propagating other that I find comical
they're funny so was it a lie it's not
even satire I'm literally just
reproducing real things that have
happened and placing it within a
schedule what I wanted to do with the
sketch the whole goal of it was just to
recognize how like even the modern
leaders at the left claims to love like
Martin Luther King his speech today
would be hindered and would be
considered non inclusive just because of
the fact that it doesn't appeal to the
language that we live with today so the
very people who champion him I would
never allow him to exist today that was
the entire point of it there's a lot of
people if you look in the comments over
like yeah it's funny but it's sad
because it's true 100% cuz you the
lander sensor got it yeah a lot of
people who don't like oh not so much so
that's it for today's video tell us what
you guys think did you guys enjoy the
sketch if so let us know your feedback
we wanna see more if you haven't seen it
there's a link below you know cuz we
starting on web see last kiss was fire
it was period and we got more coming
okay alright once we get that money we
gonna do some big teams
[Music]